[музыка]
Что такое эффект
рычага? Эффект рычага - это когда вы
маленькими усилиями и ресурсами
достигаете больших результатов. Как это
возможно, спросите вы? Вы когда-нибудь
замечали, что некоторые люди, делая
совсем мало, получают очень много, а
другие, работая до упадка, почти ничего
не добиваются? Мы привыкли думать, что
успех приходит только к тем, кто
работает круглыми сутками и прикладывает
огромное количество усилий. Но на самом
деле это не так. У нас у всех силы и
время одинаковые и
ограниченные. Никто не может достигать
больших результатов только благодаря
своим усилиям. Значит, дело в другом. А
в чём же? Давайте разбираться. Помните
историю с Архимедом, когда он сказал:
"Дайте мне точку опоры, и я переверну
землю". Так вот, вы думаете, он сказал
не подумавший или что это просто
красивая фраза? А вот и нет. Он был
абсолютно прав. Секрет его высказывания
не в его силе, а в силе рычага. Сегодня
я расскажу вам об этом удивительном
принципе, который изменит ваше понимание
того, как правильно действовать для
достижения поистине больших результатов.
Это видео для тех, кто готов думать
по-новому и действовать умно. Поэтому
досмотрите это видео до конца, и вы
по-новому взглянете на свои действия.
Уверен, результаты вас приятно удивят.
И, кстати, многие в комментариях пишут,
что это мой и Аватар делает эти видео. Я
хочу развеять их сомнения. Эти видео я
записываю сам без использования
какого-либо аватара или двойника. Ну,
для информации, чтобы снять только один
такой ролик, у меня и всей команды
уходит от 5 до 7 часов, не считая
монтажа и последующей обработки. Поэтому
не обесценивайте труд большой команды,
которая старается ради вас, чтобы
донести до вас полезную информацию,
способную изменить вашу
жизнь. Что такое эффект
рычага? Эффект рычага - это когда вы
используете минимальные усилия для
получения максимальных результатов.
Этот принцип я позаимствовал из физики и
из наблюдений в повседневной жизни. Это
не просто физический принцип, это
философия успеха, применимая во всех
сферах жизни. Представьте себе качели.
Обычные детские качели. Представили? Так
вот, на одном конце сидит ребёнок весом
30 кг, а на другом взрослый весом 80 кг.
Как вы думаете, качели будут качаться?
Конечно же, нет. Потому что вес
неравнозначный. А можно ли сделать так,
чтобы ребёнок и взрослые, несмотря на
разный вес, могли качаться? Конечно,
можно. Но для этого нужно сместить точку
воздействия и точку приложения усилий.
Это когда ребёнок отодвигается дальше от
центра к краю доски, а взрослый,
наоборот, садится ближе к опоре. В этом
случае ребёнок может легко поднять
взрослого, хотя сам весит намного
меньше. Вы наверняка замечали такое в
детстве и даже, может, даже сами это
проделывали. Вот это и есть принцип
рычага, когда малыми силами достигается
больший
результат. Давайте возьмём другой
пример. Представьте, что вам нужно
сдвинуть камень весом 100 кг. Голыми
руками и своими силами это сделать
невозможно. Но возьмите металлический
лом, подложите под него маленький камень
как точку опоры, и вы легко приподнимете
огромный камень с минимальными усилиями.
Сами вы при этом не стали сильнее, вы
просто использовали принцип рычага,
который многократно усилил ваши
возможности. Не верите? Вы можете
проверить это прямо сейчас, выйдя на
улицу и попробовав это на
практике. Кто занимается физическим
трудом, видит это каждый день. Из чего
же состоит рычаг? и как он даёт вам
силы. Любой рычаг, будь то обычная палка
или метод в бизнесе, состоит из трёх
главных
частей. Первое - это опора. Что такое
опора? Опора - это основа. Основа, на
которую опирается весь рычаг. Она держит
всю нагрузку и даёт устойчивость. В
жизни и бизнесе опорой могут быть ваша
репутация, знания и умения, ваши
ресурсы, авторитет и доверие к вам. Без
надёжной опоры рычаг не будет работать.
Точка воздействия или точка, где мы
хотим получить результат? Точка
воздействие - это место, где проявляется
результат или эффект рычага. Это то
место, где вы получаете желаемый эффект.
Третье - это точка приложения усилий.
Точка приложения усилий - это место,
куда вы прикладываете свою силу в жизни.
Это те действия, которые вы делаете
сами. Помните, рычаг работает хорошо
тогда, когда у вас прочная опора, ей
можно доверять. Вы правильно выбрали,
куда приложить усилия, то есть что
именно делать, и вы правильно выбрали,
где и какой вы хотите получать
результат, чего вы хотите добиться,
какие бывают рычаги и как они работают.
Рычаги бывают разные, и понимание их
разновидности поможет вам лучше их
использовать. Существует три основных
вида рычага. Рычаг первого типа это
когда ты используешь какую-то точку
опоры, расположенную между тобой и
объектом, чтобы с небольшим усилием
поднять или переместить большой груз.
Давайте рассмотрим примеры рычага
первого типа в жизни. Качели или доска
на бревне, когда на одном конце сидит
тяжёлый человек, а маленький ребёнок на
другом конце легко поднимает его. Если
точка опоры ближе к взрослому,
ножницы. Точка опоры посередине. Ты
сжимаешь рукоятки с небольшой силой, а
лезвия легко режут твёрдые материалы.
Гвоздодёр. Ты подкладываешь его под
гвоздь. Здесь точка опоры - это изгиб
инструмента. Даже лёгким нажатием ты
вытаскиваешь прочно забитый гвоздь. Цель
рычага первого вида - это получить
максимум результата применимо усилий.
Именно поэтому я называю этот рычаг
эффективность. Рычаг второго типа - это
когда нагрузка или твоя цель находится
между тобой, местном приложении усилий,
и точкой опорой. Примеры в жизни: тачка,
например. Груз лежит между колесом,
точко опоры, и тобой, твоим усилием. Ты
легко поднимаешь и перемещаешь тяжёлые
вещи. Чеснокодавилка или
орехол. Чеснок или орех, нагрузка
находится посередине. Точка опоры с
одного конца, а ты сжимаешь с другого.
небольшое усилие и чеснок раздавлен или
орех расколот. Открывалка для бутылок.
Горлышко бутылки это точка опоры, а
крышка посередине - это точка
воздействия. Ты легко открываешь её
простым движением руки. Цель рычага
второго вида - это создать такую
ситуацию, при которой у вас максимальные
шансы достигнуть своей цели. Вы как бы
зажимаете цель с двух сторон, не
оставляя ей путей отступления.
Поэтому я называю этот рычаг
неизбежность. Это то, что использовал
Дон Карлеона, когда говорил, что я ему
сделал предложение, от которого он не
может отказаться. Крычагу второго типа,
кстати, относится шантаж,
вымогательство, рекет, взятие
заложников. Эти ситуации именно поэтому
и заставляют других людей выполнять волю
преступников, потому что те используют
силу рычага второго типа. В народе про
такие ситуации ещё говорят. Он оказался
между молотом и наковальней. Рычаг
третьего типа - это когда твоё усилие
прикладывается между точкой опоры и
нагрузкой. Здесь ты проигрываешь в силе,
зато выигрываешь в скорости и точности
движений. Давай те приведу примеры из
жизни. Пинцет. Обычный медицинский
пинцет. Точка опоры на одном конце,
пальцы усилия посередине, а предмет
нагрузка на противоположном конце. Ты
легко и точно берёшь мелкие вещи.
Возьмём удочку. Ты держишь удочку,
задний конец, точка опоры, прикладываешь
усилия посередине руками, а крючок с
наживкой, нагрузка далеко на другом
конце. Твоё небольшое усилие позволяет
делать точные, быстрые и дальние
забросы. Кнут. Ты ладонью держишь ручку
кнута, а пальцами прилагаешь усилия. В
результате мы имеем высокую скорость
хлыста. Лопата при копании. Одна рука
точка опоры, а другая посередине
прикладывает силу. Земля - это нагрузка.
Скорость работы высокая, но сил
требуется гораздо больше. Целью рычага
третьего вида является получение
быстрого результата, даже если для этого
нужно приложить больше усилий или больше
ресурсов. Это как кончик кнута или удар
ракеткой. Поэтому я называю этот рычаг
рычагом скорости. Когда время очень
важно, этот рычаг особенно полезен.
Здесь идея простая: время дороже денег.
Вы тратите больше ресурсов, чтобы
получить результат
быстрее. И это оправдано, когда скорость
решает успех дела. В жизни мы зачастую
пользуемся этим рычагом. Например, для
того, чтобы быстрее распродать свои
остатки, свой товар, мы зачастую делаем
скидки и быстрее достигаем своих целей.
или когда мы доплачиваем за более
быструю доставку, или когда мы спешим
куда-то и прикладываем наши усилия и
ресурсы туда, где это даст нам
увеличение скорости. Как мы увидели в
жизни, есть три основных типа рычага. Мы
уже частично рассмотрели то, как они
выглядят в повседневной жизни. Давайте
более подробно остановимся на том, как
применять эти рычаги для достижения
наших целей. Для этого нам нужно ещё
классифицировать рычаги для более
точного понимания, как их можно
использовать. Есть шесть основных
способов применения рычагов. Первое-
преобразование энергии. Это рычаги,
которые превращают один вид ресурсов в
другой, более ценный. Это вот как,
например, рычаг переключения передач в
машине. Вы свою физическую энергию
превращаете в механическую энергию
автомобиля. Например, в бизнесе
использование своей репутации для
привлечения денег инвесторов. Вы не
тратите свои деньги, но используете
доверие к вам, чтобы привлечь чужой
капитал или в жизни. Учёба в
университете превращает ваше время в
более высокую зарплату в будущем.
Второе. Накопление энергии. Это
использование накопленной энергии или
ресурсов. Это как заводить пружину
часов. Сначала вы тратите силы на завод,
а потом часы долго работают сами. В
карьере это накопление опыта и навыков,
которые делают вас ценным специалистом.
Сначала вы долго учитесь, но потом уже
можете использовать эти знания много
раз. В бизнесе - это когда вы долго
раскручиваете свой бренд, а потом бренд
и репутация работают на вас. Пример в
жизни: создание денежных резервов или
накоплений, чтобы потом использовать их
в трудные времена. Третье.
Перенаправление внешних сил. Это рычаги,
которые перенаправляют внешние силы в
вашу пользу. Это как парус, который
ловит ветер и использует его для
движения вашей лодки. Например, в
бизнесе продажа своего товара через
Amazon вместо создания собственного
магазина с нуля- это передача работ в
аутсорсинг. Это использование трендов и
общественного мнения в свою пользу. Это
использование солнечного света для
обогрева дома зимой благодаря
правильному расположению окон.
Четвёртое. Умножение эффекта. Рычаги
умножители эффекта используют несколько
рычагов одновременно, создавая цепную
реакцию усиления. Это как система
блоков, где каждый блок увеличивает
силу. Например, в бизнесе создание
франшизы, где ваша бизнес-модель
порождает новые бизнесы, которые платят
вам. создание команды, которая умножает
ваши усилия, или в жизни обучение других
людей тому, что вы умеете, и они, в свою
очередь, учат других. Так ваше влияние
распространяется всё шире. Пятое.
Уменьшение сопротивления. Уменьшители
сопротивления снижают трение и устраняют
препятствия. Это, знаете, как смазка для
механизма, которая позволяет ему
работать легче и быстрее. Пример в
бизнесе: упрощение рабочих процессов,
чтобы быстрее выпускать новые продукты.
Правильная мотивация сотрудников,
поставщиков и потребителей в жизни.
Организация рабочего места так, чтобы
все нужные инструменты были под рукой.
Шестое. Усилители резонанса. Резонансные
усилители создают эффект раскачивания,
когда маленькие воздействия в нужный
момент дают большой эффект. Это как
качели. Если толкать их в нужный момент,
они раскачиваются всё выше. Пример в
бизнесе. вирусный маркетинг, когда один
человек делится вашим контентом, и это
вызывает цепную реакцию, когда делятся
уже многие в жизни. Выбор правильного
момента для просьбы или предложения,
когда человек наиболее склонен
согласиться. Давайте рассмотрим примеры
применения рычагов в жизни. В личной
жизни, например. Регулярные занятия
спортом и правильное питание дают со
временем огромные результаты. при не
таких уж больших ежедневных усилиях или
возьмём казный час, который я применяю
ежедневно у себя. Этот час направлен на
повышение моей эффективности. Так вот,
всего один час, потраченный на повышение
моей эффективности в день, даёт мне
колоссальные результаты. Возьмём
планирование. Потратьте всего 15 минут
на планирование дня, и вы можете
сэкономить часы и сделать намного
больше. Обучение.
Изучение любого нового навыка требует
сил вначале, но потом приносит пользу
годами. Возьмём
наставничество. Найдя хорошего
наставника, вы можете избежать множество
ошибок и быстрее достигать своих целей.
Возьмём пример из бизнеса. Чужие деньги,
например. Использование кредитов или
инвестиций для расширения своего
бизнеса, это тоже является рычагом. Хотя
я против использования кредитов в целом,
но в данном случае я просто описываю,
как работают рычаги.
или делегирование. Это когда вы
передаёте задачи другим людям, чтобы
самому сосредоточиться на главном. Или
возьмём рекламу через довольных
клиентов. Это когда ваши клиенты сами
рекомендуют вас другим. Или возьмём
франшизу, когда ваша бизнес-модель
масштабируется другими, а вы получаете с
этого выгоду. Или возьмём пример с
использованием чужих знаний. Это найм
экспертов вместо самостоятельного
изучения всех областей. В инвестициях
это называется кредитное плечо. Это
когда вы используете заёмные или
инвесторские деньги для инвестиций,
увеличивая свою потенциальную прибыль.
Или совсем бытовой пример - это ипотека
для покупки жилья. Вы живёте в квартире
и одновременно становитесь её
собственником, не имея при этом всей
суммы сразу. Давайте рассмотрим
опасности рычага, потому что у вас может
сложиться впечатление, что рычаги - это
только хорошо. На самом деле рычаги не
настолько безобидные и полезные, как
может показаться на первый взгляд.
Рычаги, на самом деле, это больше как
увеличительное стекло для ваших усилий.
Они могут быть как полезными, так и
опасными. Всё зависит от целей, с
которыми вы их применяете. Несмотря на
все плюсы, рычаги при этом имеют свои
опасности, о которых вам лучше знать.
Первая опасность или первый риск - это
зависимость от других. Эффект рычага
часто зависит от внешних ресурсов, что
может создавать риск потери контроля,
уязвимость к изменениям вокруг и
необходимость постоянно поддерживать
отношения с теми, кто даёт вам ресурсы.
Второй риск - это сложность управления.
С ростом системы становится сложнее ею
управлять, требуется больше внимания,
больше контроля, а также сложнее найти и
исправить проблемы. Увеличение рисков.
Рычаг усиливает не только хорошие, но и
плохие эффекты. Финансовый рычаг,
например, увеличивает не только
возможную прибыль, но и возможные
убытки, а ошибки в большой системе могут
привести к цепной реакции проблем.
Долгое время
ожидания. Создание хороших рычажных
систем часто требует времени. Многие
виды рычагов требуют больших вложений
усилий в начале, и первые результаты
могут появиться далеко не сразу.
Типичные ошибки при использовании
рычага. Стратегические ошибки. Первая
стратегическая ошибка - это выбор
неподходящего вида рычага. Это
использование финансового рычага там,
где нужен социальный. Второе-
неправильный выбор точки приложения
усилий- это концентрация на мелочах,
которые не дают большого эффекта. Третье
- это игнорирование необходимости
прочной опоры. Попытка использовать
рычаг без создания надёжной основы.
Давайте рассмотрим тактические ошибки.
Слишком большой рычаг- создание системы,
которая слишком сильно зависит от
внешних ресурсов. Второе - это
недостаточное внимание качеству, то есть
расширение бизнеса в ущерб качеству
основных процессов. Нетерпеливость
ожидание мгновенных результатов от
рычагов, которые работают на
долгосрочной основе. Эффект рычага - это
не просто физический принцип.
А универсальная идея, которую можно
применять почти в любой сфере вашей
жизни, от финансов до личных отношений,
от бизнеса до образования. Везде можно
найти способы применения этого мощного
инструмента. Помните, суть использования
рычага не в том, чтобы работать меньше,
а в том, чтобы достигать больших
результатов. Это не про лень, а про
умную работу. Главное понять, что ваши
собственные усилия нужны в основном для
организации направления внешних сил, а
не для выполнения всей работы
самостоятельно. Вместо того, чтобы
тянуть всё на себе, научитесь создавать
системы, которые будут работать на вас.
Отсюда вывод. Эффект рычага - это не
просто способ сделать больше с меньшими
усилиями. Это философия эффективности,
которая позволяет нам достигать наших
целей наиболее оптимальным путём,
используя не только наши собственные
ресурсы, но и силы, существующие вокруг
нас. Освоив этот принцип, вы сможете
достигать результатов, которые раньше
казались вам невозможными. И делать вы
будете это удивительно эффективно. А я
на этом прощаюсь с вами и желаю вам
почаще задумываться об эффекте рычага в
своей деятельности и максимально его
использовать.
[музыка]